battlefield one isn't out yet but we  already know about its DLC plans I'm  Tony and this is your world war 1 era  GameSpot news update battlefield ones  Premium Pass will get you monthly battle  packs that include new weapons dog tags  and guns plus early access to new maps  and four expansions and we already know  what that first expansion will be they  shall not pass releases in March 2017  and focuses on the French army the  second expansion will highlight the  Russian Empire after that and premium  pass holders will get into the new  content two weeks early  the first battle pack will be available  this November battlefield one releases  for ps4 Xbox one and PC on October 21st  if you want the premium pass it'll cost  you fifty bucks you can expect dice to  announce plenty of new content down the  road so stick with GameSpot  to stay up-to-date and for all the  biggest battlefield news you're already  in the right place